[Musique]
donc miss de chaud ne manquez pas le
spectacle
de plusieurs années je veux un film qui
m'a profondément marqué un film fait par
un québécois jean bodin des grands
acteurs québécois pascal bussières john
maine le titre du film souvenirs intimes
attention ce film très dur les personnes
qui m'ont reproché de ne pas les avoir
prévenus alors je ne prends plus de
chance dans ce film une scène que
changer ma vie est un jeune homme
d'environ 16 17 ans qu'un accident de
voiture très grave il se cache la
colonne vertébrale très haut il va être
paralysée jusqu'en bas pour le reste de
ses jours il ne s'est pas encore est
dans le coma la scène qui m'a marqué la
scène au cours laquelle il vient de
sortir du court mais bien d'ouvrir les
yeux il le médecin doit lui apprendre
qui va être paralysée jusqu'en bas pour
le reste de ses jours ce n'est pas
facile à faire mais faut que quelqu'un
le fasse le médecin s'approche de lui et
lui dit ceci à partir d'aujourd'hui et
les prononce trois mots je vous assure
c'est trois mollahs sont devenus les
trois mots les plus importants dans ma
vie fait trente ans que je travaille sur
le stress la fatigue et l'épuisement la
perte d'intérêt la démotivation j'en
suis arrivé à la conclusion que ces
trois mots là enfermé la clé de notre
pouvoir sur le stress une grande partie
de la clé de notre pouvoir sur notre vie
si vous le reteniez que ces trois mots
là de toute la conférence seront valu la
peine à mes yeux
le jeune homme est sorti du coma le
médecin s'approche de lui et lui dit
ceci à partir d'aujourd'hui tu devras
les places et ton attention trois mots
classé ton attention sur la région ton
corps qu'il y entre la base et on est à
l'extérieur
et se découvrir toutes les sensations
que tu apportes
un site encore les picotements les
châtiments les engourdissements je me
faisais une scène extraordinaire est en
train de lui redonner son pouvoir parce
que le danger qui guette ce jeune homme
c'est d'aller placer son attention
uniquement dans la région de son camp
qui est morte et deux n'habitez que là
pour le reste de ses jours catastrophe
pourquoi moi c'est pas juste ma vie au
dessus on se le cachera pas vous qui lie
pour faire le deuil
et vous qui ramène son attention dans
des régions de son corps qui sont
vivantes pour pouvoir en profiter le
médecin sort de la chambre une très
belle fame
on s'aperçoit qu'il a oublié de dire
quelque chose et retourne dans la
chambre il s'approche du jeune homme me
dit ceci est dans mes shows ne manquent
pas le spectacle je me dis c'est
fabuleux y est entrée d eric caute même
si dans la colonne crasse et ici était
paralysée jusqu'en bas et en corée
spectacle disponibles et en tiens toi
maintenant d'avoir l'attention
nécessaire pour pouvoir en profiter
c'est tellement vrai l'histoire que je
vais maintenant vous raconter je tire un
écrivain examen anthony des mélos dont
j'aime beaucoup les écrits et qui
racontait l'histoire suivante à acheter
les billets pour un spectacle anton mais
chaud aujourd'hui vaut s'y prendre
maintenant en avance vous avez acheté
d'excellents billets non plus tard c'est
le soir du spectacle
c'est un milieu de la salle dans milieu
d'une rangée les lumière s'éteint les
rideaux sont les spectacles commencent
ça fait un an vous attendez vous
éprouvez nécessairement un bien-être de
la joie mais après trois quatre minutes
de cette petite fois qu'ils commencent à
jacasser dans votre tête ça fait plus de
trente cinq ans que je la paie notre
petit hamster intérieur et commence à
courir comme ça dans ces petits trous et
l'aï fait est-ce que j'ai verrouillé ma
voiture
et là ça court ça court je vais quand
même pas me lever tout de suite je suis
dans le milieu l'arrangé il fait lourd
je veux déranger tout le monde ça court
ça court vous avez encore un tract
arrive vous trouvez même que ça ne pense
pas vite mais ça fait un an que vous
attendez d'un tract arrive vous
précipiter vers une voiture elle était
verrouillée mais vous avez manqué manqué
toute la première partie du spectacle
pour 1 seule raison parce que votre
attention était ailleurs vous êtes en
vacances sur le bord de la mer vous
bercer doucement dans un hamac la
température est idéale une petite brise
qui caresse votre peau ce petit bruit
des vagues comme une musique et même une
part de votre bouche qui descend dans un
verre avec quelque chose que vous aimez
et là en vacances sur le bord de la mer
dans un hamac le siams terre commence à
courir il fait je recommence à
travailler dans trois jours est un
élément c'est le syndrome du ballon bull
le ballon dans l'estomac et la boule
dans la gorge portant la même
température mem brise de même un mac a
même pas même vague que j'étais pensée
seule chose c'est là où est rendu votre
attention c'est une question
fondamentale
plus je vieillis plus je trouve que le
spectacle il est court c'est le 30 ans
que je fais des personnes qu'ils
fonctionnent plus au travail elle arrive
dans mon bureau plus les fid est épuisé
mon travail s'était accompagnée dans un
retour dans un travail le même un autre
peu importe mais que ces personnes ne
puissent travailler à nouveau elles ont
en commun deux phrases la première je ne
sais plus qui je suis identité je ne
sais plus où je vais sens et on
travaille ensemble à partir d'une
question qu'est ce qui fait que la vie
vaut la peine d'être vécue et d'une
réponse ce qui fait que la vie vaut la
peine d'être vécue dépend de l'eau je
place mon attention est ce qu'elle est
accaparée par le hamster je suis né j'y
arriverai jamais ou si elle est sûre le
spectacle l'enfant qui raconte sa
journée
la campagne qui rit les sensations que
j'éprouve pour profiter au maximum du
spectacle doit découvrir où est mon
attention elle ne peut pas être deux
places en même temps et pour découvrir
où est mon attention je dois m'arrêter
il ya deux mots qui m'aident à m'arrêter
vigilance conscience où est mon
attention mais aujourd'hui c'est de plus
en plus difficile de nous arrêter
pourquoi parce qu'on est en train de
vivre une mutation se sont pas d'accord
mais qui pousse ce ne sont pas des cas
et qu'ils apparaissent sur leur rapport
au temps t mts et par le fait même aux
autres qui se modifie en grande partie à
cause de l'arrivée des nouvelles
technologies dans nos vies attention je
ne veux pas préjuger de retour en
arrière j'y crois aux nouvelles
technologies je laisse mon téléphone
cellulaire je laisse mon ordinateur
portable grâce aux technologies en
contact avec ma famille qui vit ici en
france ma fille mes petits fils mon
gendre le problème ce ne sont pas les
techno le problème c'est la mutation qui
s'opère en nous à travers le rapport
qu'ont au techno on l'a ressemble où est
mon attention vigilance conscience
plusieurs années j'ai soigné une dame
qui elle aussi a changé ma vie et c'est
monsieur depuis que nous avons un fax
notre organisation un fax et en un objet
de musée 1 et 2 il ya deux phénomènes
premier phénomène l on dirait que quand
quelqu'un ment voir documents par fax il
ya l'impression qu'en rentrant dans
l'appareil est rentré ctte mans dans mon
cerveau
il téléphone à sursis le duel à distance
et une nouvelle exigence je n'ai pas
répondre à cette existence là il ya
quelques années que faisait ton quand on
n'avait pas de sphinx écoutez bien son
analyse elle est magnifique elle on
prenait un document ont glissé dans une
enveloppe et on met un terme dessus elle
de ce petit geste monsieur
conditionner notre rapport au temps et
aux autres et c'est parce qu'on estimait
que ça prenait 2 à 3 jours à se rendre à
destination
on donnait aux personnes auxquelles
étaient destinés à deux journées pour
qu'elle en prenne connaissance
aujourd'hui on le document l'appareil au
téléphone le dessus le tout lui est
envié de comprimés notre rapport au
temps on vient d'un seul coup
d'augmenter les exigences sur soi même
on veut tout de suite et sur l'autre
personne on veut sa réponse tout de
suite et on vient d' altérer le rapport
entre nous on vient de jouer dans la
soutient la reconnaissance l'entr'aide
trois facteurs collective très puissant
pour prévenir l'apparition du stress ou
leur réduire ce qui est déjà paru madame
z deuxième phénomène monsieur j'ai
développé un nouveau reflex ça c'est une
mutation et nouveau reflex à chaque fois
que je reçois un document par fax je me
dépêche à lire je me dis si ont pris la
peine de me l'envoyer par fax ça doit
être parce que c'est urgent je
l'écoutais parler j'étais rempli de
honte je me faisais messieurs deux mois
dont elle parle assez que quand elle est
sûre si j'ai failli lui demander combien
je lui devais pour la consultation
mais je me suis à partir de demain matin
ça va changer à partir de demain matin
je reprends mon pouvoir sur ma vie je
ris harmonise mon rapport au temps et
aux autres pas avec de la pensée magique
avec des gestes concrets posés chaque
jour passage à l'action la première
chose que j'ai dite est de faire il ya
plusieurs années tout mon environnement
d et r j'étais pas sérieux suffira pas
ça tu es malade chez oui je veux faire
je prends mon pour à son avis je serai
harmoniser son rapport au temps et aux
autres la première chose que j'ai lesté
de fer ya plusieurs années c'est de
faire un effort particulier pour arrêter
sur les feux oranges loge appris
beaucoup de choses d'abord il faut
toujours vérifier dans son rétroviseur
prête ce cas pas quelqu'un trop proche
en arrière j'ai appris aussi beaucoup de
choses sur le comportement humain
surtout sur le langage non verbal
mais je m'étais dit j'ai toujours avant
un livre avec moi c'était entre une vive
une mutation je voulais rentabiliser les
feux rouges je t'ai dis à chaque fois
que j'arrivais au feu orange d'élire
deux paragraphes à la fin de l'année
j'aurais lu un livre au complet j'ai
jamais eu le temps de prendre le lead de
l'ouvrir de trouver où j'étais rendu ça
klaxonnait rien je me suis dit ben
voyons dont je pensais que c'était plus
longtemps un feu rouge
j'ai décidé de faire un projet de
recherche j'ai la chance d'avoir sur
maman un chronomètre je me suis dit ça
sera pas compliqué à chaque fois que
j'arrivais sur le feu orange je vais
appuyer sur le bouton il voit partir
quand le feu va devenir vert je dois
appuyer sur le bouton il va arrêter et
quand j'aurai le temps je ferai la
lecture je me suis mis à avoir du
plaisir à faire ça j'en ai fait des
centaines j'ai eu un choc profond j'ai
découvert qu'en moyenne un feu rouge je
le sais il armé dit plus long mais y en
a aussi des picots j'ai découvert que ça
durait en moyenne 30 secondes mais je me
suis dit mais c'est fascinant parce que
toutes les personnes qui m'ont envoyé
des sillons non verbaux faut quand même
se placer dans un état particulier pour
envoyer des signes on lan verbaux pour
sauver 30 secondes s'organisent pour les
pères à la fin de leur vie parce que ça
use à l'état comme ça ça use mais là je
me suis mis à observer sa d'innombrables
endroit si vous le faisiez casse à
partir d'aujourd'hui je vous le garantis
signe en bas de la page en trois copies
votre monde changeait et peut-être que
notre monde changerait j'arrive dans un
immeuble centre-ville à montréal matin
22 étages
j'aurais chaussée je viens d'appuyer sur
le bouton de l'ascenseur la petite
lumière est allumée une flèche verte je
recule il y avait une autre personne
elles font sur la bouteille comme ça
c'est un voyant donges à l'époque ça
faisait descendre les ascenseurs a plus
vite là je me suis dit imaginons un
instant que ça ferait descendre les
ascenseurs plus vite ce cas est vrai aux
personnes qui seraient déjà dans
l'ascenseur
pigeon conscience où est mon attention
on pense pas une seconde que si ce geste
fonctionner on ferait s'écraser a pas
tellement d'alphonse plancher le pire le
pire c'est que ça modifie les rapports
que nous avons les eaux et les zones
avec les autres c'est ça qui est grave
vous êtes au supermarché avec la petite
poucette nous attendait dans la rangée à
l'accueil au moment où tout arrive il ya
quelqu'un qui ouvre son porte-monnaie et
commence à compter ses pièces sa part à
courir leinster comme un sphinx et je
sais moi que ça les bilans et conscience
j'ai parlé dans un centre hospitalier
j'y retourne la semaine suivante une
dame qui m'arrêtent d'un corridor fait
penser à vous cette semaine ça fait
toujours plaisir j'ai dit ah ben on a
dit oui j'étais au supermarché avec ma
petite roussette j'attendais dans la
rangée à la caisse a dit tout à coup
j'ai regardé la question et j'ai fait au
nom je suis coincé avec la nouvelle vous
savez celle qui décrit en formation là
aussi
je vous ai pas cru j'ai fait ce que vous
aviez dit dans ma tête ça fait finances
conscience je suis ouvert une fenêtre de
lucidité dans laquelle j'ai placé les
trois phrases frigo vous aviez suggéré
pourquoi des phrases frigo parce qu'on
devrait les coller sur la porte de son
réfrigérateur pour les voir souvent avec
elle j'ai pris note neurologie première
phrase frigo revient si bien ici ramène
ton attention sur quelque chose de
concret d'un respiration t au
supermarché la deuxième phrase frigo
acquis chez mal acquis cheval son
supermarché que mathis est la seule
personne à qui chemin c'est à moi et je
me fais pas seulement psychologiquement
mal je me fais bien logiquement mal
vient de déclencher une propre et
biologiques dans mon corps rythme
cardiaque en sûreté réelle cholestérol
sanguin ça s'envole
troisième france frigo c'est une
question je l'emprunté un auteur ton
prénom et écart de notre famille tall et
diacres un livre qui s'appelle le
pouvoir du moment présent je pense que
d'avoir saisi tous cas dans le livre
mais nous propose une question magique
une des plus profondes que j'ai jamais
entendu de toute ma vie je l'utilisé
plusieurs fois par jour ne me croyez pas
utiliser la jeune est question suivante
est un problème en ce moment la partie
importante de la question c'est en ce
moment chaud supermarché avec ma petite
poussette est un problème en ce moment
j'ai parlé c'est dans une usine à la fin
à john coupe s'avance vers moi monsieur
ce soit monsieur je me suis réveillé
j'ai envie de vous raconter ce que je
vais vous raconter mais peut-être que ça
va être seul ado nous on à nouveau les
on a chacun notre puits pour donner le
biberon et la nuit dernière c'était mon
tour savez mon bébé dans les bras comme
ça je trouvais qu'il pleuvait tellement
lentement je me suis mis à pousser sur
le sac comme ça il faut aller chercher
une paire de ciseaux pour couper la
tétine beaucoup trop soit plus grand
dans une école il ya une femme qui
venait me voir rouge comme une tomate à
masi monsieur moi aussi j'ai honte mais
peut-être que ce après tout c'est la dot
j'ai moi je suis bout'chou tous les
matins l'habiller c'est l'enfer et mexes
et pantalons son chandail à 17 les
plombs tous les matins j'ai trouvé un
truc je l'habille l'abeille
est est ce que je pourrais avoir votre
opinion c'est avec plaisir madame je dis
moi j'aime bien séparer le jour de la
nuit ça se pourrait qu'il soit un petit
peu mélangé à 10 avez-vous le truc je
dis oui pourriez vous levez crise
minutes plus tôt elle a fait
[Musique]
les enfants apprennent par modélisation
quel genre de modèle sommes-nous en
train de fabriquer et d'offrir ne me
croyait pas ne croyez rien de ce que je
vous ai dit fait la russie revient ici
acquis cheval est un problème en ce
moment et surtout surtout dans mr chow
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]